Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
So after my video last week, a Nerdfighter
posted this picture to twitter with the caption,
"Who wore it better, Tom Hanks in Castaway
or John Green in Vlogbrothers?"
Also, someone in comments noted "The puff
seems to have migrated south for the winter."
So yeah, I trimmed my beard, okay.
In other news, Hank, there is this line from
my book Paper Towns, "I'm in love with cities
I've never been to and people I've never met,"
and that line has been quoted a lot over the
years.
I mean it pops up all the time on Tumblr.
It has over seventeen hundred likes on Goodreads.
Now, it's no, "If people were rain, I was
a drizzle and she was a hurricane."
It's not even one of the most quoted lines
from Paper Towns, but it's definitely sort
of widely out there in the world.
There is even a poster available at DFTBA.com
designed by Nerdfighter Risa.
Now, Hank, to be totally honest with you,
I don't remember writing the words "I'm in
love with the cities I've never been to and
people I've never met" but then again, I don't
remember writing a lot of Paper Towns.
That book came out seven years ago.
Sometimes I'd be on the set of the Paper Towns
movie and I would be like, "Why is this happening?"
and Jake Schreier, the director, would be
like, "Because it's in the book," and I'd
be like, "Oh yeah, right, how is the book
anyway?
Is it good?
I hear there is a little bit too much Walt
Whitman."
So yeah, when I started seeing the quote a
few years ago, I just assumed that it was
in Paper Towns; people kept sourcing it as
being from Paper Towns.
I suppose instead of blindly assuming I'd
written something that the Internet said I
wrote, I should've done some research, but,
you know Hank, how many of us have failed
to fact check something on the internet?
Most I would think.
Flash forward to last week when I come across
a post on the copyright subreddit, and it's
like, "My friend wrote a thing on Tumblr that
is now being attributed to John Green; in
fact, like, they're selling a poster of it,"
and then at the end of the post she was like,
"You can just control-f and search for that
quote in Paper Towns; it is not there."
So I did.
I illegally downloaded a pirated copy of my
own novel, I hit control-f, I searched for
the quote.
Sure enough -- not there.
So Hank, it turns out "I'm in love with cities
I've never been and people I've never met,"
was written by a thirteen-year-old Nerdfighter
several years ago.
On her Tumblr, she often quoted my books a
lot and made art using quotes, and so someone,
somewhere assumed that line was written by
me, and then yeah.
Now this poor young Nerdfighter, Melody, gets
lots of hateful asks in her Tumblr inbox from
people who are like, "Why are you stealing
John Green's quote?!"
I stole it!
I am the thief!
So Hank, just to be clear, we've been selling
a poster with a quotation attributed to me
that was in fact written by a thirteen-year-old
Nerdfighter.
Now obviously Melody and Risa are going to
share the royalties from that poster.
We're retroactively paying Melody for the
posters we've sold so far, and also when I
saw this artwork of Melody's I was like, "I
really like that; we should make that a poster
at DFTBA.com," so now we have, it's available
for pre-order.
All the royalties go to me, no, they go to
Melody.
Now Hank, admittedly I'm a bit of a grapefruit
for getting into this situation in the first
place.
Like, this isn't the first time that a quotation
has been misattributed to me.
Like, there's that line from the series finale
of the television program One Tree Hill that
has been attributed to me like seven hundred
thousand times on Tumblr, but I did not write
that.
But I think a wrongly-attributed author, even
a very grape-fruity one, failing to notice
the misattribution in question, speaks to
how screwed up credit and sourcing and copyright
are on the internet.
We do an especially bad job of acknowledging
one another's work and checking our sources.
So Hank, there's my story of how I came to
believe I'd written something I actually hadn't.
Hopefully, we've gotten it right now, but
I'm sure that somewhere, someone's copyright
is still being violated in all of this, which
reminds me to tell you, Hank, that starting
soon over at Crash Course there will be an
introduction to intellectual property and
copyright law, which is a great interest to
all of us who care about the internet and
also like, art and the making of things, so
you can check that out soon at Crash Course,
and hopefully, together, we can get better
at this stuff.
In the meantime, please support Risa and Nerdfighter,
Melody by getting their posters.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.